[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous et à toutes donc moi ben
comme a dit JP je m'appelle Sébastien
donc moi j'ai vécu depuis 8 ans un
voyage mais vraiment extraordinaire avec
ma structure qui s'appelle zoulou avec
justement je pense que vous l'avez
compris avec des husky donc c'est cet
husky sont très différents les uns des
autres donc évidemment je vous ai
apporté le fameux chips qui est l'alpha
donc après j'ai eu milky qui sont très
importants pour moi
Maya les deux mamans ils ont fait
respectivement 8 bébés et 4 bébés on en
a gardé deux de chaque de chaque portée
donc en fait moi depuis 8 ans évidemment
vous ce que vous avez l'image c'est des
chiens de traîneaux ces chiens de
traîneaux j'aurais pu proposer mon
reparticuliers de faire de l'attelage à
la base mais depuis 8 ans petit à petit
je me suis reconverti entre guillemets
par la force des choses de tout ce qui
est médiation animale donc je sais pas
si vous connaissez un petit peu la
médiation animale voilà la médiation
animale c'est vraiment
l'équithérapie pour le plus gros ou
vraiment où il y a des personnes en
maison de retraite par exemple qui
peuvent apporter des petits animaux de
type hamster lapin pour donner la
valorisation des connaissances par
exemple pour les personnes âgées en
milieu comme Alzheimer et moi petit à
petit vous pouvez le voir aussi sur mes
réseaux j'ai vraiment tout le panel tout
le panel on parle de d'enfants qui sont
handicapés polyhandicapés des IME
jusqu'à aux maisons de retraite alors
que je parlais il y a aussi la justice
la justice je sais pas si vous avez ce
regard mais c'est vraiment énorme ça
peut être des foyers avec des enfants
placés pour des violences pour faire
simple mais ce que je veux vraiment vous
faire comprendre c'est que il y a
vraiment
déjà par rapport à ce que j'ai vécu
c'est juste énorme le fait que je sois
là et qu'on m'appelle c'est vraiment une
réussite pour moi mais vraiment j'en
aurai presque les larmes aux yeux même
d'être devant vous c'est pour moi c'est
pas évident de parler c'est je suis un
référent je suis un médiateur c'est
comment je dirais mes chiens sont les
acteurs premiers de ce que je peux vivre
mais vous imaginez même pas le poids que
j'ai de vivre ça au départ si vous
voulez par exemple je vous donne un
exemple quand je commençais à faire des
activités par exemple avec des enfants
proposaient beaucoup de choses je
proposais par exemple à mariage de chien
les enfants ils choisissaient un chien
je faisais du parrainage maraînage de
coeur et je me suis rendu compte qu'avec
le temps c'est
je servais à rien en fait le silence
comme on a fait tout à l'heure c'est
vraiment moi ce que je propose et petit
à petit je me suis rendu compte dans
tout le les activités que je fais même
avec les particuliers c'est vraiment
cette relation avec l'animal ce contact
que j'ai avec les chiens et les
personnes qui viennent aussi bien les
particuliers aussi par rapport à mes
potes qui font l'attelage que vous avez
tous vu que ça soit la télé ou vraiment
en vrai dans les Alpes ou même par ici
dans le pied là où personne Mazel si je
me trompe pas qui font l'attelage eux
ils ont vraiment de l'activité pure ces
chiens là et là vous pouvez voir que
chips il est vraiment passif et par
rapport à nous à notre communication on
est vraiment sur sur comment je dirais
l'instant quand je reçois des
particuliers c'est vraiment un moment de
pique-nique par exemple et qui sont
autour des chiens et petit à petit on va
faire de la randonnée une forme active
mais une forme passive mais aujourd'hui
vraiment c'est ce que je veux moi vous
que vous boutonnier c'est que c'est pas
que j'en ai marre mais qu'on dise il
faut profiter du moment présent il faut
donner du bon sens à la vie mais les
tout tous mes clients tous les résidents
que moi j'ai ils le savent on n'a pas
besoin de sa fin c'est juste mon avis
évidemment sur le moment sur l'instant T
justement
il le savent de profiter du moment
présent mais ils ont une pathologie mais
moi ça fait par exemple 8 ans et j'ai
aussi une autre activité en tant que
surveillant nuit avec des porteurs de
handicap adulte
j'ai jamais entendu de leurs mots
l'handicap c'est nous qu'on a un regard
et par rapport aux animaux évidemment là
je vous la prends pas mais ils ont pas
ce regard là ces chiens là en meute ils
apportent tellement de choses
chez les professionnels et aussi chez
les résidents donc moi en fait je suis
là pour vous décrire vraiment ce que
j'arrive à vivre mais vraiment que vous
compreniez que
ce message que j'ai à passer c'est tous
les héros de tous les héros la liaison
pas les 0 les héros du quotidien c'est
j'ai l'image de mon épouse qui
institutrice vraiment mais qui est une
femme au foyer avec trois enfants avec
un mari atypique qui paraît mais
vraiment on les entend pas tous ces gens
là mais non avec cette modernité des
réseaux des de tout ce que vous voulez
on n'a pas cette base on a plus cette
base de
du silence de toujours de la réflexion
comme tout à l'heure je vous ai dit
prendre du recul sur les choses mais on
l'a en nous toutes ces émotions qu'on a
vraiment en
perspective justement où on se dit dans
les moments où ça va pas se dire waouh
j'ai toujours cette image de mon
expérience de vie quand on est en par
exemple en situation de d'enterrement
dans une église on a cette émotion qui
redescend on a cette pensée de la
personne qui vient de décéder de près ou
de loin mais on a cette émotion on se
dit on se rappelle des gens qui ont été
là pour nous
vraiment compter là rien que le fait de
vous le dire je présume que ça vous
remet en situation
mais moi c'est ce que je vis tout le
temps depuis 8 ans c'est mon expérience
et j'en ai voulu faire un travail j'en
ai les gens franchement j'en ai vu j'en
ai fait une vocation mais
enfin par la force des choses quoi
donc voilà donc après par rapport à la
préparation de cette petite conférence
j'ai pas l'habitude moi évidemment
parler devant autant de personnes entre
guillemets et j'ai fait comme tout le
monde je me suis dit
je suis allé voir les réseaux Youtube
pour TEDx
je suis allé voir comment ça se passait
à la fabuleuse cantine et je me suis
rendu compte que moi-même je faisais
l'erreur de me dire alors comment on
parle dans une conférence alors il faut
d'abord parler mettre en contact les
gens avoir un cheminement et je me suis
dit c'est peut-être une erreur de
ressembler à tout le monde et d'avoir ce
cette situation où on se dit
on va faire comme tout le monde et je
pense que vous allez voir avec les
autres speakers où ils ont vraiment une
histoire comme moi avec tout ce que je
vais vous dire et tout ce que je vous ai
déjà dit et c'est pour ça que j'ai un
peu triché entre guillemets et j'ai un
peu mon déroulé donc depuis 8 ans j'ai
réussi à combattre beaucoup beaucoup de
choses il y a 8 ans quand on m'appelait
surtout en mode professionnel
c'était des gens des structures
hiérarchiquement on va dire je sais pas
moi les directeurs directrices il
m'appelait pour une animation de se dire
wow tes photos sont trop belles tes
chiens sont trop beaux mes endroits de
retraite on va faire une photo et eux
ils se servaient ça pour montrer que
financièrement ils font des choses pour
la maison de retraite aujourd'hui quand
on m'appelle moi déjà je mets un
je vais appeler ça un ancrage ou c'est
moi qui va dire non quand moi je viens
par exemple en unité Alzheimer
c'est vraiment les personnes que j'ai
dans la salle il faut qu'il y ait un
résultat donc là on va parler de
pathologies la pathologie en fait quelle
que soit la maison de retraite où les
enfants c'est vraiment il faut vraiment
qu'il y ait une
un résultat pas spécialement positif
mais vous pouvez tout imaginer parce que
vraiment je sais pas si vous avez un peu
ce regard de mon monde à moi tout ce qui
est foyer tout ce qui est les enfants
sourds et malentendants les cliniques
les cliniques de repos pour des gens qui
sont vraiment en niveau plus plus ils
ont pas une pathologie physique qui va
ils vont bien contre guillemets mais là
ça va parler du mental et les animaux
c'est ce lien là et ça j'ai
même moi moi je suis le premier client
de zoulou c'est vraiment je sais pas si
vous avez vraiment ce regard et petit à
petit vous allez la voir
de vraiment se contact avec l'animal
donc voilà donc on a tous
je vais appeler ça cette communication
humaine cette domestication
et c'est pour ça que moi d'ailleurs je
me suis beaucoup fait décrié d'avoir
pris des huskys grossièrement les chiens
là on va rentrer plus dans le vif du
sujet des chiens en fait ils sont
divisés en 10 catégories et plus ou
moins dans le dans Comment je dirais
dans l'époque comme les husky on va dire
qu'ils sont primitifs donc grossièrement
parce que évidemment c'est faux ce que
je vais vous dire ce vu je suis filmé il
faut pas travailler des bêtises mais ça
fait 200 300 ans qui sont à côté de
l'homme en husky Sibérie en Sibérie et
c'est moi là où j'étais le premier
surpris la réaction de mes chiens par
rapport à mes résidents mes clients tout
ce que vous pouvez imaginer c'est juste
extraordinaire mais vraiment c'est juste
extraordinaire je sais pas je vais vous
donner un exemple qui était pas prévu
mais
ce schizophrène la maladie la
schizophrénie quand j'ai des personnes
schizophrènent ils ont la gestuelle très
brusque et moi qui suis praticien
massage canin quand je les mets sur une
table de massage je parle des chiens et
qui viennent qui viennent s'approcher
ils vont être brusques avec ces chiens
là cette chiens différents et ils vont
voir les six autres résidents par
exemple où ils vont pouvoir les
papouiller les caresser et faire de la
manipulation avec
et d'habitude ils sont accompagnés que
ça soit ce schizophrène que je prends
l'exemple mais ça peut être des enfants
aussi l'autisme par exemple si vous avez
un peu ce regard sur l'autisme c'est
vraiment de la violence interne
et
à chaque fois mais pas une fois je loupe
un rendez-vous c'est un miracle les gens
qui les accompagnent les éducateurs tout
ce que vous voulez ils vont se mettre en
retrait automatiquement parce que les
enfants les personnes de type
schizophrène auront avoir moi ce que
j'appelle un accrochage et suivant les
personnes vont avoir un accrochage d'une
séance d'une heure une heure et demie
cinq minutes mais c'est 5 minutes là je
vous jure c'est juste extraordinaire
donc voilà après j'ai plein d'expérience
par exemple en maison de retraite une
fois je suis allé en maison de retraite
c'était le la première fois dans cette
maison de retraite où j'avais un groupe
de personnes âgées qui étaient assis
et je faisais un petit jeu de croquettes
les chiens je donnais aux personnes
âgées des croquettes à droite à gauche
comme vous pouvez imaginer et j'avais un
monsieur qui qui ne parlait pas qui
avait perdu son épouse trois mois avant
et depuis trois mois il parlait pas et
il était bien enfin il marchait quoi ça
comme ça mais là depuis trois mois il
est en fauteuil roulant et parlait plus
il était ce que décompensé quoi
il m'a regardé
il m'a pris des croquettes dans la main
déjà c'est un mix pour moi un miracle il
a regardé l'éducatrice il a fait comme
ça
donc moi j'ai eu un petit stress comme
un dessin animé une petite goutte et
même Marcel et puis elles sont pleurer
mais ça je l'ai à chaque fois vraiment à
chaque fois donc cette manipulation des
chiens je vais vous faire une petite
démonstration
entre guillemets
voilà avec chips
vous voyez comme il est calme j'en suis
même étonné si mes enfants pouvaient
être pareil donc je voulais vraiment
avant de passer à chips ce monde
professionnel ce monde professionnel que
vous pouvez penser les éducateurs spé
les les aujourd'hui en iOS les moniteurs
éducateurs tous ces gens là aussi même
en maison de retraite tous les personnes
que vous pouvez imaginer qui font le
ménage qui sont comme moi surveillant
nuit
qu'on voit aujourd'hui un peu mis en
avant par rapport aux infirmiers à
l'hôpital truc comme ça mais c'est pas
que le salaire c'est vraiment comme je
disais une vocation ces gens là ils sont
à même titre que que ce que je vous
présente aujourd'hui c'est vraiment des
gens mais juste extraordinaires on a
l'exemple des sages-femmes qui eux font
un métier énorme donc voilà la
proposition moi que je vais vous faire
c'est que je vais vous démontrer quelque
chose par rapport à ce que je propose il
faut imaginer que je suis
évidemment avec quelqu'un comme un
enfant comme des personnes à difficulté
mais pas que les particuliers et je leur
dis toujours je travaille toujours par
trois
c'est ce que vous êtes vous devant le
canapé
c'est de se dire waouh j'ai passé une
furet purée de journée et vous vous êtes
toujours comme ça vous êtes où on va se
mettre de la crème entre guillemets
c'est hyper important c'est une base
c'est une base et pour moi les chiens
c'est ce que je propose
généralement et réellement tout le temps
toujours ce niveau par 3 pourquoi parce
que j'estimage là je l'ai appris moi par
la force des choses cette maman j'ai
toujours l'image de la maman qui a son
bébé qui la met dans ses bras et vous
pouvez toujours regarder ce bébé il a
toujours la tête vers le cœur
et moi qui suis praticien de massage
canin je j'appelle ça l'accrochage
donc je vais essayer ça dépend
évidemment de chips
il était bien
donc cette accrochage ça va être facile
aujourd'hui je sens qu'il découle donc
ce fameux crochet marche toujours niveau
par 3 donc ce niveau 1 c'est ce que vous
faites tout le temps avec n'importe quel
animaux et même ce que je vous disais
tout à l'heure avec le canapé vous êtes
tout le temps mais vous verrez c'est
machinal et humain
vous le caressez vous le papouiller
donc ce niveau là on va essayer d'être
que vous essayez donc on va pouvoir le
papouiller et voyez sa réaction juste
ici quoi le niveau 2 que je propose
c'est
c'est on va dire prendre soin de
l'animal le toilettage les peigne donc
on va le on va le peigner
et le niveau 3 mais c'est là où c'est
très important cette fameuse maman avec
la tête de l'enfant c'est l'accrochage
c'est accrochage vous pouvez faire
n'importe quoi vraiment avec un cheval
avec tout ce que vous voulez cache avec
un chat ça marche aussi c'est accrochage
c'est le plus important de tout ce que
je vais vous démontrer c'est cette main
qui va commencer à le manipuler
vous voyez tout de suite sa tête et
surtout chez les chiens à l'oreille où
il va commencer à kiffer
et ce niveau 3 en fait si vous voulez là
je vais un peu vite pour
pour aller un peu vite aussi par rapport
à la conférence ce niveau 3 en fait
c'est ce que vous connaissez peut-être
le mot efflorage pour les chiens en fait
c'est des poils
c'est on va pas toucher la peau et on va
toucher les points donc là change
l'accrochage
et je touche pas là pour le niveau 2
évidemment c'est la peau
je vais essayer d'arriver comme quand
vous êtes chez l'ostéo il va commencer
par la colonne vertébrale même si vous
dites que vous avez un problème au bras
est alors je vous parlais du silence
vous voyez chez vous ce que ça fait ce
silence est apaisement et c'est imaginer
les enfants qui sont vraiment dans ce
calme là
vous voyez plus son petit plus je leur
dis ben on va essayer d'endormir le
chien donc moi je leur dis écoutez je
suis un hypnotiseur et quand j'arrive à
hypnotiser les chiens alors vous allez
essayer d'hypnotiser les chiens les
enfants quand ils peuvent évidemment
et ce niveau 3
c'est d'aller là j'étais au niveau 2
vers la peau ce que j'appelle le pyjama
et là on va essayer d'endormir le chien
avec ce fameux niveau 3
et ça ils adorent les enfants je leur
dis attention chips tu vas t'endormir à
un
à 2
2 et demi
et 3
je sais pas si vous imaginez c'est là où
devant vous vous avez un husky sibérien
qui fait du chien de traîneau mais c'est
des chiens de traîneau qui fait de
l'attelage
et évidemment c'est l'accrochage depuis
tout à l'heure c'est l'accrochage donc
je tiens aux enfants je suis hypnotiseur
je suis Messmer
et ça ça marche tout le temps tout le
temps tout le temps et vous pouvez faire
tout ce que vous voulez vous voyez cette
assemment qu'on a en nous là
cette conférence elle sert à ça donc
voilà j'espère que ça vous a plu
merci beaucoup vous me faites beaucoup
beaucoup de bien et par rapport à la
vidéo je veux vraiment finir sur ça
c'est très important pour moi par
rapport à tes enfants que je connais
on applaudit pas dans le monde dans
l'handicap on fait comme ça
merci merci à vous
merci
[Applaudissements]